and finally new rule instead of saying
both parties are equally to blame for
the mess we're in just admit you haven't
really followed politics for the last 20
years now everyone is mad at Howard
Schultz for thinking he can be the
barista in chief but nobody is attacking
his central premise that we need an
independent because both sides have
become equally extreme now I'm not here
to pick on Howard I don't believe in
kicking billionaires when they're down
and besides there's some professional
courtesy involved I also was once a drug
dealer but this idea of a pox on both
their houses is just factually wrong
there's a pair of highly respected
scholars named Norm Ornstein and Thomas
Mann who've been analyzing Congress for
half a century always criticizing both
parties in equal measure
but then around 2012 they started
writing something very different summed
up in their article let's just say it
the Republicans are the problem they
wrote the Republican Party has become an
insurgent outlier ideologically extreme
scornful of compromise unmoved by
conventional understanding of facts
evidence and science exactly Congress is
not broken the Republican Party is
broken
so when I hear Howard Schultz say we are
sitting today with approximately 20 1.5
trillion of debt which is a replica
example not only of Republicans but of
Democrats as well it's obvious he just
hasn't done his homework Bill Clinton
left office with a surplus Obamacare was
paid for and Obama's bank bailouts
necessary because of a Republican
recession were paid back
Reagan W and Trump all ran up huge debt
with tax cuts for the rich and their
party continues to practice trickle-down
economics long after evidence has shown
it not to work yes evidence only one
side generally trades in reality anymore
Trump has made over 8,000 false or
misleading statements as president
nothing like this has ever happened
before yes all presidents lied to a
degree but Trump is in a world of his
own he's Bob Beamon at the 68 Olympics
breaking the long jump record by two
feet
he's Babe Ruth hitting 59 home runs when
the previous record holder had 27 he's
he's he's Tom Brady winning six [ __ ]
[Applause]
but this leveling of truths is a war
being waged on democracy by only one
side fifty-one percent of Republicans
still believe in birtherism I once joked
the Trump was the son of an orangutan
and he sued me for it but it didn't
become a foundational belief of the
Democratic Party
a majority of Republicans believe
Hillary ran a pedophile ring out of a
pizza parlor they believe three million
people voted illegally in 2016 they
believe reverse racism is a bigger
problem than racism if you drew a Venn
diagram of insane and 21st century
Republican it would be a circle after
you'll get your shot after this and okay
and over time you'll get a rebuttal
Howard Schultz says both parties engage
in revenge politics but it wouldn't have
even occurred to Democrats that you
could simply refuse a president to fill
a Supreme Court vacancy Mitch McConnell
did that he said I know it's in the
Constitution I don't care
make me both parties are not extreme
that's extreme
Al Gore conceded the 2000 election for
the good of the country would Bush have
would Trump only one party thinks it's
okay for presidents to have a side gig
as a Russian agent Trump fired the head
of the FBI for doing his job with the
Russian investigation then he had the
Russians over and laughed about it
that's not a bipartisan problem if Obama
did it he'd be in Supermax now trading
cigarettes with the Unabomber and are
you really going to tell me that both
sides are equally to blame for the state
of the environment one party trusts the
science on climate change and the other
asks how can be warming if I'm holding a
snowball so when you say they're both
equally bad just know that doesn't make
you a sage it's a stupid person's idea
of a smart thing to say it's a cheat
that says you're above it all when
you're really just too lazy to tell [ __ ]
from shinola
it's
and it is the central fraudulent idea
that allowed an outsider like Trump to
get elected it's one step up from I
don't vote it's like claiming that I
don't read makes you smarter and I don't
shower makes you smell good
you